Reckless riding continues to be a
problem on our robes with kids riding
their bikes into oncoming traffic and
many in the Southern Highlands Community
say they're fed up Madison Kimbrough
joins us live near Cactus and Dean
Martin tonight A prominent spot where
these kids ride Madison
tonight we hear from residents one of
whom is a CCSD bus driver who says
driving home has become a nuisance with
kids popping wheelies and doing tricks
out on the roadways
there was at least another
20 25
and I just had just passes and by the
time my wife got her phone out that's uh
that was the second half the group that
we saw and then we smelled you know some
of them are smoking weed a lot of them
were standing on the handlebars of their
bicycles Barry a Southern Highlands
resident shared this video with 8 news
now that his wife took just a couple
weeks ago near Olympia Park a spot where
a lot of riders frequent he says with
their pack mentality parents need to be
aware that this Reckless writing is
causing a major safety hazard in their
neighborhood I think for parents to
realize that the kids are running around
in a pack of possibly 50 and sometimes
antagonizing the older members of the
community and someone's going to get
hurt and it's going to create a problem
for
the person that hits one of them
Jennifer feeler a CCSD bus driver who
also lives in Southern Highlands says
she sees it on her routes while picking
and dropping off kids from school and
even when driving home from work as it's
a constant concern it's happening on a
daily basis where I have
um mostly Middle School age students
that will weave in and out of the cars
at Bell time grabbing onto the buses
doing wheelies and
riding straight into the oncoming
traffic as for what can be done these
Southwest Valley residents want more of
a police presence in their area
patrolling the streets and feeler adds
that having CCSD police nearby would
also be beneficial since it happens
quite a bit when school gets out
writer sharing with me that if they had
a bike park in the area to go to they
would with the nearest one being in the
Silverado Ranch area but because of the
distance they tend to migrate to the
streets reporting in the southwest
Valley Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now